big cloud is so addictive and so much
fun
and so lucrative so far on paper that
i just can't i can't talk about anything
my wife wants to throw me out of the
house right now like
so the good news here guys is that i
signed up for big clout but i pretty
much
only signed up because ryan just called
me and said uh i want to talk to you
about this
sign up i i don't really know what it is
so you guys could talk about it and i'll
be the one asking the questions on
behalf of the audience
right like an idiot so let's let's take
a stab because it's kind of new and
foreign and most almost i would say 99
of the people listen to this are not
active on bitco yet um let's each take a
stab at it ryan and see
if we can get to a simple explanation of
what the heck it is
so here's my here's my simple
explanation sam big clout is basically
like a stock market for people so me and
you and ryan and anybody else
uh we each have like a little coin a
price
where you could buy some of our stock
let's call it um
and so people are going on there and
they're using bitcoin to buy
our stock because they believe that
we're going to continue to get more
popular
and our reputations are going to grow
and that owning a piece of our limited
um coin uh the you know if i own ten
percent of your
your stock basically uh i feel good
about that because i think in the next
10 years you're gonna be
getting even more popular right so it's
a way to bet on people
and so that's the which we which we've
talked about a lot we love this
we've we've looked at humanity like what
we talked about before which is like is
it for income sharing
is it for x is it for y is it for z
right now it's literally for nothing and
so the
reason this is cool right now is because
uh nobody knows who's behind it they're
kind of like
being stealthy about it people know but
nobody has publicly outed who's
who's behind it um i do know the name of
the
people behind it but i know people who
know the person people i trust
say they know who it is and they because
i asked they they were like yo i'm
buying your coin are you gonna
are you gonna actually use big cloud or
not i was like well i don't know is this
like a scam it kind of looks scammy to
me
and they were like yeah i thought so too
because kind of the
the secretive way that they're going
about it but actually i know the
founders they're like legit people from
the tech scene they like kind of have a
reputation in our circles
um and a bunch of the big name tier one
vcs are involved in it
now that doesn't mean it's not gonna
fail it doesn't mean it's not as
like maybe something unethical is gonna
happen or that's gonna get hacked or
who knows any any number of bad things
can happen but it's not
random guy and you know not nigerian
prince is kind of the
the main thing that that i've heard now
you
you guys you're forgetting a major part
here which is if you go to big
it's bit clout c-l-o-u-t dot com
you can't actually do it you don't have
a password it's all
you need a password so you guys are
forgetting it's inviting only right now
and you have to have
this you know similar to clubhouse and
superhuman like you know this is
one of the techniques in silicon valley
now to build hype
and get early adopters to want to in is
to not let them in and then
make it so they can only get in if they
have the secret secret codes
so okay right that was my my attempt
what would you change about it how would
you describe it differently
yeah i know i think you nailed it i mean
it's a social currency platform
i think you put it more simply you can
bet on people so like take sam
so i called sam last night i'm like dude
what the heck are you doing how are you
not on big cloud yet
you need to get on here you need to
create your profile so he goes on he
creates his profile
i put in two thousand dollars into this
at the same part on big cloud
i then you know i i then
watched it overnight and when i woke up
this morning i had already made like
five six thousand dollars what and so
yeah
so ryan let's walk through me and sam's
coins so can you just pull up
actually the site's down which which is
sort of problematic besides that
so so that's a that's a bit of an issue
it'll come back up but it's getting
hammered with traffic i think so last
ice last you saw ryan what was my
coin trading for and do you remember my
market cap
i don't i'd so it's so annoying the
sights down because i was hoping to have
it ready
but i want to say you you were pretty
legit first off i just want to say like
you're you're
you were trading at a at a relatively
high number relative to like your fame
and like your twitter handle
you were which which i what i've noticed
is people who are known in the crypto
world
disproportionately are doing well on the
platform so like
like i bet yesterday on chuck norris and
i'm
because because part of my strategy is
to buy people who are
trading at a cheap number relative to
like the following they have on twitter
or instagram
and like [__] norris was trading at like
200 dollars but
you know he's got a huge like he's a big
following he's obviously pretty famous
even though he's like
you know a scene celebrity but
i don't get any of that you do
so you can set whatever percentage you
want to take of the
of the coin that people invest in so the
default is 10
so if i buy like a thousand dollars
worth of sample
i believe the way the math works is uh
you'll take ten percent of that in coin
and so what's cool about that is like as
you become more famous as you build up a
reputation
and as you keep your reputation you know
good in the public eye
like in theory your big clout uh market
cap will grow
and you'll take ten percent of that now
what i've seen some people do
who have money like you sam is they they
set their percentage down at zero
instead of ten percent which is the
default because they don't want to
discourage people from buying their
their coin and then they just buy their
own coin
and then they bet on themselves which is
something oh my gosh
as okay i saw this a few days ago and i
saw
oh wow some people have bought like i
think somebody had bought thousand
dollars worth my coin
um and basically i was trading for
almost two thousand dollars per coin
and my my own holdings that they kind of
like give you
through your i don't know if it's like a
founder reward or like a
a ten percent vig you hit on every buy
or something like that
my own holdings if i claimed my account
i had sixty thousand dollars worth of my
coin ready for me so the the
the genius of their model is this wait
you had six
months my own coin what i what they
basically what i had gotten from the way
that the site works
if i if i verified my account so here's
how it works this is the genius the
growth hack that they have which is
very very smart and so what they do is
they pre-made all of our accounts they
took the top 15 000 twitter accounts i
think
and they made profiles for all of them
they made coins for all of them
immediately
and then they let some people in with
bitcoin to go buy up whoever they wanted
so people start buying coins
and of course every time you buy a coin
the default is a 10
if i buy 100 coins of yours 10 of those
coins go to you
and 90 come to me so there's like a like
the brokerage fee
goes to the creator themselves so what
this did was you're elon musk you're
naval you're
you're you know on a smaller scale us um
and you you go on the site and right now
it basically says
cool if you log in and verify that you
are you you you
are sean vp on twitter you get to claim
your coins
uh your coins are sitting there in this
account so i have a 60 like
last time i checked this was a few days
ago but before several friends bought my
coin so i might have more now
but i had a 53 000 uh
bounty just waiting for me all i had to
do was connect it to my twitter account
and tweet out
hey i'm on bitcloud you know like uh
come buy my coin or whatever
if i did if i know i didn't do that
because at the time i didn't know
is this legit am i promoting a scam and
so i went did some background checks i
asked a few people who i knew were
buying my coin i said
what you know is this real or is this
not like ryan you know and others
and so um and so that's how simple it is
so so think about that mechanism
right now i have cornered the sandpark
market if you look at sampara i
are his biggest holder um and
and i plan to buy more sandpark as soon
as the site comes back
guys listen it wasn't like
it wasn't i can't tell you what's like
the red pill blue pill phrase
what's the what's the what's the pill
that you take what your perception is
completely changed
it can't go bad okay maybe i'm just like
a blue pill guy here
but like it wasn't that long ago that i
was so
poor that i would put two pieces of
pizza into one whole foods box and
so i could just like only pay for one or
where i would like eat
half the food out of my container before
i weighed it
uh like it wasn't that long ago that i
was that poor where i
where i was stealing food from the
grocery store now
we're talking about sean just logging in
and being like oh
beep bop boop fifty thousand dollars in
my account yeah
does this stuff freak you out this kind
of freaks me out no it does not freak me
out at all i think it's awesome that i
could log in and get 50
000 i think that's cool now okay here's
some of the criticisms right uh and this
is where sam your [__] detector is
about to like
you know fly around the room you're
about to raise your eyebrows all the way
to the moon when you hear this which is
that
you could transfer money in and you
could buy coins but there's no
withdrawals right now
you cannot so i could go in and verify i
could claim my fifty thousand dollars
what i can't do is put that in my bank
account
um that's a feature that conveniently is
not available and not built yet now
they are going to do it um the the main
thing for them is that
um they say oh we're building it it's
not ready yet
in reality my theory is basically if you
allowed people to immediately come in
grab 100k grab if i can come and grab
50k
withdraw it out of the system it's going
to kind of crash the network
it's not going to like the whole system
kind of fails there's this there's a
theory about sort of um
you know like one of the reasons bitcoin
is so valuable is because the central
philosophy of the religious bitcoin
holders
is to hold the coin uh if you're selling
out of it the price drops
and so what they want right now is for
everybody to hold their hold coins
so that the network can get big enough
get enough strength and then it once
it's bigger and more popular
you can add liquidity and people can
trade it and now and it won't just
completely crash the system
so do we just have so much money going
around right now that we have to invest
okay so here's okay so let me explain to
you because i also was like what the
hell is this
and then i was sent the one pager and i
want to actually read to you guys
the one pager pdf uh this might be a
little boring
a pdf but honestly when i read this so i
talked to ryan i don't know like
40 minutes ago on the phone before this
podcast i was like yo
okay we're coming on i'm excited about
big cloud i heard a little bit about it
but i haven't had time to look at it i
just had a kid
like i haven't had a chance to go in and
kick the tires and he was like dude
this is like the most you're right you
said this right you're this is the most
addictive thing since
for early facebook for you the craziest
thing i've i've been i'm like all my
friends have been up all night like
one one's in alaska heli skiing another
one is in utah like we're all
texting all night hey who's buying chuck
norris has anyone
figured out like oh i just 10xed on
gwyneth paltrow
like a number a number of my friends
like guys who worked for me at summit
who have like maybe 50 000 saved have
put in like a quarter of their net worth
and in the last like four or five days
of five to 10x their money right
like but they can't get anything out
they can't get enough they get it out
yet but i i contacted the founder of a
pretty major
um like crypto hedge fund and he assured
me that
they bet quite a lot on this and that
he's confident that they will there will
be a way out plus the founder also said
that
eventually there'll be an exchange you
know where you could sell it
um it's just the easiest thing i've seen
let me give you both how do i make
sampar
the game style yeah yeah well first of
all calling it game stock is perfect
that's all right you're already memeing
yourself
stop yeah whatever so okay so here's the
okay
because when we were talking on the
phone ryan i was like so you're buying
my coin
great what what's the reason why would
you want my coin what does that do for
you
like i get that if i get more popular in
theory my coin could get more popular
but that assumes more people will want
to buy it
why would they want to buy it what are
they getting out of this it's like well
then they
think you're going to get even more
popular then the next person will want
to buy it right so there is definitely
like a greater full theory
that underlies this whole thing which is
that i'm buying it today because i think
somebody else is going to come buy this
tomorrow
either because the creator i'm buying is
going to get more popular
or big cloud is going to get more
popular in reality right now
both are going to happen and um and so
so i think it's actually a
good bet even if you know going in that
this is
greater fool theory this is i'm i'm
looking to pass this to the next guy and
make
a lot of money before the music stops so
i think that's the skeptical way of
looking at it
now let me tell you the like why this
actually might be a thing long term
and i'm going to read to you from the
pdf um
what they say this is okay so sam i'm
going to read read this to you and you
just tell me paragraph by paragraph
is your belief going up or down okay
um where did you find this i just
googled bit
yeah i'll send it to you it's a white
paper
where are you guys getting this bro
we're connected on the inside not
connected enough to know who's actually
doing this but connect enough to know
the people who know the people
um all right so big cloud is a new type
of social network that lets you
speculate on people
and their posts with real money as built
on a blockchain okay cool then it goes
uh it's a fully open source project um
there's no company behind it just coins
and code
so then it says um let me skip to the
part about crater coins
what are crater coins everyone has a
coin every profile on the platform gets
its own coin that you can buy and sell
these are crater coins uh you get one
you get you can have your own
creator coins just by creating a profile
and they already pre-created a whole
bunch of profiles
because you know i didn't do it but my
my creator coin exists
okay then i had to make mine then it
says
you can buy your favorite person's coin
to buy someone else's to buy someone's
coin you just go to their profile you
click buy
uh for the top 15 000 influencers on
twitter it's preloaded into the platform
um okay cool so now uh
then it says tweet to claim your profile
the owner of a profile
uh can claim their profile by tweeting
out their public key
um this will give them full access to
their account as well as the percentage
of their founder rewards which is
that's what i was talking about my 50k
that's sitting there for me that's my
founder reward for claiming my account
now the genius of it is
by me tweeting out like i have a big
incentive to tweet this out right
because i get access to my fifty
thousand dollars
so they're basically kind of like paying
me fifty thousand dollars to tweet out
about big cloud and if enough of the
and the bigger you are the bigger your
reward and so they're gonna get a lot of
big people to tweet this thing out which
is going to create this like
enormous hype cycle um okay so then it
says
what are creator coins useful for so
this is where it starts to become
interesting it goes
there's a new asset class that's tied to
the reputation of an individual
for example let's say elon musk succeeds
in put being the first person to land
uh land on mars put a person to mars his
coin price should theoretically go up
because he will be world renowned for it
um and if in contrast he makes a racial
slur during a press conference his coin
price should go down because his
reputation takes a hit his popularity
uh goes down so you as a trader can make
money by buying and selling the ups and
downs of
speculating on a person's future
popularity okay so then it says
state what could you use the coins for
um so today it's just about buy and sell
but in the future let's say
that you know right now for example i
think craig clemens is my biggest coin
holder he has like i don't know ten
fifteen thousand dollars in my coin
ryan's got a right how much of my coin
you got worth
um i think i bought like three four
thousand dollars
what can i do to reward the people who
own my coins so that more people want to
buy my coins so one is a stakeholder
meeting
so you could basically say okay i'm
going to do an ama or a q a for anybody
who owns over
you know 100 of my coins at whatever
so what do you tell them like hey
everyone i wanted to give you an update
on the next quarter
i'm thinking that i'm not going to say
anything just because you're racist
but i am going to do that i am going to
film someone committing suicide which
might make my think you're like report
about your
own popularity you're saying okay for my
super fans who want access to me you
want more access like let's say
you know like for example our friend
andrew wilkinson has done a thing where
he says
cool buy this expensive thing for
charity and you get to do a lunch with
me or you get to join this ama's q a
exclusively with me and 25 people who
pay the five grand to this all the
proceeds go to charity
it's that same idea if people want to do
a want to ask you a question or whatever
so here's a simpler version right that's
like you get to attend a
private meeting for people who own x
amount of my coin
the other way is to say look i get a
bunch of spam in my inbox every day
people email me people dm me and
literally this is true there's so many
of those that i don't respond to 90
of them and unfortunately some of the
good ones just get mixed up in
all the random junk that people send me
so here's the thing i have an inbox the
inbox is a
has a contract that basically says
anybody who um
if you want to message me it costs you
five coins um
and my coin has a real price so you you
you can do that by either having a huge
amount of my coin or going and buying
some in order to message me
and i will respond to everybody who rep
who sends me this paid message
through this channel right so now i can
have an inbox that has a price with it
or i can prioritize it based on sort
this by my biggest coin holders because
those are my vips i want to talk to them
first i want to give them replies first
another another idea they have uh
sponsored posts
so i can have an inbox that basically
says you can pay me
you can you can buy a certain amount of
my coin and i'll retweet your thing
um and so it's just a simple like you
don't need an
essential middleman agency to set up
like these paid promotion deals it's
just i just set a price
or people just bid a price and i just
look at it and i say okay i'll take 100
coins 100 of my own coin
for posting this thing i don't mind i
actually like the thing you told me to
post
and then the last one like there's an
only fans version of this where
cool if you have this man if you pay
this much coin of my coin per month you
get exclusive content
the last one is what they call money
likes so let's say
uh like let's reimagine the like button
so instead of just being able to smash
like on everything
let's say that it costs a tiny amount of
coin to like something so
for me putting out a good post like
let's say that clubhouse thing i did
that went viral
today all i got was fame i didn't make
any money off the fact that seven
million people saw that thing twitter
made money but i didn't make any money
so in this case if i put out great
content that goes viral like my my
clubhouse thing
then every person who's hitting the like
could be basically
buying in order like they're buying a
micro amount of my own coin
and so i earn for posting good content
um
in that way and by the by that person
buying my coin by hitting like
they're actually sort of investing in in
me right because they hit the like let's
say it costs one
sean coin to do it they bought one sean
coin they hit the like button because
they like my content now let's say i
keep getting more popular they still own
that coin so our
both of us have an incentive to do that
those are some of the ideas what do you
think
where i am right now is like it's
there's one of three things happening
one either my iq is just low enough that
i can't keep up with you guys when you
discuss this
two um i'm just out of touch and like
it's happening where like
when my wife started getting a job at
facebook her dad was like why do you
need it why do they need all these
people it's just a web
it's just a website like am i am i
getting
am i getting out of touch or three um
this is [__] and i'm right well can
i can i give you a simpler use case
well right now i'm uh you know i've been
doing executive coaching i think as you
guys know and i've been
i'm coaching the the founder and ceo of
morning brew and i think
we should pick austin reef and
alex lieberman a morning brew against
the sam
at the sam par on big cloud i'm i'm
going to
buy coin in all of them and let's see
who can become
the bigger market cap in the next 30
days
but i don't want to do that like i'd
wouldn't it be better if i just spent
time in like making money on [__] that i
own in the entirety of
but these this is like the i thought
these guys are like like your nemesis
this is a newsletter war
between the hustle and the morning the
final i've cashed out dude i've won
like i like
like i i have everything i need i've
i've i have
i've won my game as far as i can tell
austin is crushing you on big cloud in
terms of his market gap right there he
goes
now now those competitive juices are
starting to flow he's like i don't care
but if you're saying he's crushing me at
a game i don't care about
i start to care about the game a little
bit no i have the game i care about
is my bank account and what time i could
wake up in the morning
your popul no that's not my big account
what how many houses you'll be able to
cash
scenario one these guys never build a
way to cash out this whole thing is a
scam
all the smart people that are involved
in it are wrong cool there is a
percentage chance that that is true i
don't know what that percentage is might
be one percent might be 50
let's just take that off the table
because if that's true then yeah there's
no discussion it's stupid
and useless if if you're buying if you
can only buy in but never sell out like
you know what is this you know robin
hood like you can't you can't do that so
here's the the other side of it let's
say it is liquid
where you can trade some of your coins
for actual cash if you want it
or bitcoin if you want it um but people
are going to be betting on hey
this podcast going gonna keep getting
more popular sam's gonna keep getting
more popular he's gonna keep doing more
things i've seen his twitter account
growing
he posts awesome content i want to get
on on the ground ground floor of sam
and they start buying your coin because
they want to hold a piece of
the sampar popularity like clout score
basically
and they believe more people are gonna
buy it so now more people do start
buying it
and um your stock goes up your stock
goes up because you sold the hustle
and then this podcast hits number one on
the charts and more people hear about it
and then we do some viral thing and then
that goes viral you get more popular
there
now what but shaw do you actually want
this do you actually
want yes people betting
i'll say something i like about it is
i've always kind of
tried to be an early adopter of certain
things right that i was excited
and like naturally curious about and i
would tell all my friends but i had no
way of like
riding the wave with the person i was
popularizing
i would go i'd be like yeah you really
should check out this awesome musician
and then they would just get really
famous and like they would get way
richer
and in fact i often couldn't even talk
to them anymore because they became too
big a deal to even you know return my
calls
and like i would have liked to have been
like on the ride with them like
financially
that would be really sam i met you
before you started the hustle
right and i was like this guy's the [__]
this guy's you know totally switched on
he's dynamic dude okay
if you could if i could have just bought
stock in you and not
bet on like for example i had the
opportunity to invest in the hustle the
media company i was like well i don't
know if this is gonna be like
this humongous billion dollar company or
what i don't know if this fits my
profile whatever
i don't know about media but i was bet i
was believing in you
the whole time and if i could if i could
have just bought sam
and owned sam for 25 years that's
something i want to do
i think that you are going to become a
hitter and you're already on your way to
becoming a hitter
and if i could have done that from the
beginning or like you know we've talked
about the founders of calm i was
buddies with them early on now calm is
so big that i feel guilty even hitting
them up to go hang out with them because
i'm like ah they just
everybody wants their time they're busy
with their you know huge company
what am i gonna do i really wanna go
hang with them now so you know i'm a fan
from afar now
but at the time if you said that you
could buy alex too and you could buy
michael actin smith
you could buy their uh their their coins
i would i would bet in all my friends
coins right
i and i do with my time but i don't ever
get to benefit financially
from spotting future stars today
i uh that was a good speech i think that
i'm a little bit
uh on board now dude i feel the exact
same way there's so many entrepreneurs
including
uh the guys at com that i met through
summit early on
and for whatever reason i didn't persist
in getting didn't get the ability to
invest in their company
you know they it was mentioned i i
didn't i didn't like you know i missed
the email
a friend of mine heard about it i wasn't
at the right event when they were
raising i met him three months earlier
whatever
now i can actually bet on these people
it's it's i don't know well
this is one there's two there's two huge
problems is the fact that you've just
put
tens of thousand dollars on this website
and you get you can't get the damn thing
to [__] turn off
right now for this entire podcast this
podcast has been on for 45 minutes and
it's
it says big big clout is under brief
maintenance all
funds are safe thank you for your
support it's a black screen with a red
text yeah
i remember when facebook first came to
my college and i was like we were one of
the first
colleges and i remember like calling it
was really fun that this is the first
time i felt like that in a long time
that's why i wanted to come on the show
and talk about it but there's two major
differences which is you didn't have
money on facebook
and two you you knew a little bit about
the background and who made it
we're looking at this anonymous thing
that isn't working and you have money on
it
that's a little nerve-wracking and also
you can't even get your money back out
if you want to by the way sam do you
know how many of my like angel
investments went to like i had no clue
someone was like you should try like
this guy
said from this person then you should
throw 50k
and i was like what the least i could do
could i do 10k okay cool here's 10k
and you know so over i think now 25 of
those or so have gone to zero
but a few of them pop so i i'm looking
at this like an angel investment right
like i'm looking at this as like
one in ten but i get it i'll do it
i'll do it but i'm not gonna like i
think that people like youtube
need someone to criticize you because
like just everything on paper that we're
doing here it's just like this sounds
like a
horrible total scam and i think you
should be optimistic about it and i'll
definitely dabble in it
so here's the other thing right like
let's let's say you said something
earlier like facebook didn't have money
in it like i think you meant i think
what you meant was
you didn't have to put in tons of money
to bed and facebook you could just start
using the thing and it's kind of like
you know
the risk like brian just said that that
his
uh normal young friends had a quarter of
their life savings
uh you know yolo so
so okay so so here's the part that i
think is exciting and a lot of people
have talked about this this is the first
attempt
that it actually clicked with me and i'm
like oh this might actually work
so there's a whole bunch of people that
since crypto came out that were like oh
my god
we need to take the social networks and
we need to convert them into crypto
networks basically what we need is
why don't like why does facebook and
twitter and instagram why do they make
all the money and we do all the work
we make the content we like each other
we put our attention and our time into
viewing the content viewing the ads
and um advertisers spend all the money
and they don't you know
they're hoping to make a return on the
other side but the users who do all the
work to on these user-generated content
platforms reap
only social value no financial value
and so a whole bunch of attempts were
made people tried to make steemit which
was like reddit but like
instead of the karma being kind of funny
money it was like real money you know
type of thing but never took off and uh
but the the fundamental always did make
sense which was
if you did get on a platform early and
you were one of the people that helped
make it big
why don't you ever get any reward for
that if you were one of the first uber
drivers first airbnb
host first power users on instagram you
know like what is it worth for those
people that are on clubhouse today
that are making content you know
freaking 24 7 and trying to make
clubhouse successful
and they're they're not the investor in
clubhouse it's you know andreessen
horowitz and like
easy and kevin hart and [__] and so um
so easy he's not an investor but well
because he's dead one thing i love about
this that you're saying is when i got
into some of these
you know awesome investments like uber i
couldn't share them with anybody i'd
call my mom and be like you really um
sorry but i i can't even get you i
couldn't get you in
you know and now it's like i feel
excited i wanted to come on the show and
like share it with the listeners
and like share it with trends because i
was like [__] everybody as soon as i get
this password and as soon as the site's
back up
like we can all actually we're like as
soon as the site works
and as soon as they open it and as soon
as withdrawals happen this is totally
gonna be sweet
but until those three primary
fundamentals work
this is garbage i say i was rightfully
pointing out the obvious
i feel like i can rule the world i
travel never looking back